you today marking the first day of
another back to school for clark county
student and employees yeah thousands
returning after a five-day pause mary
jane belliesa has more on how the
district is regrouping
it's the first day back to school after
ccsd's five-day pause carl meisner
reported no issues this morning dropping
his son off at school meisner said while
his seven-year-old was excited to get
back to class he is concerned about
another five-day pause in the future
while i certainly hope it doesn't have
to happen a lot uh it is a disruption
not not just to
us as the parents and having to find
you know the child care but
i think it really weighs on on him
not having that regular routine
and
yeah even even with the five days he was
starting to get a little antsy it seemed
so dr monica cortez assistant
superintendent says the five-day pause
allows school staff to recover from
school shortages and mitigate coveted
cases in order to safely keep schools
open in person we are going to continue
moving forward with those protocols they
worked very well for semester we know
over the holiday there was also a surge
with
our
situation
as well as a shortage so i really
believe that we'll continue moving
forward sonia pedowick is a mother of
three kids pedowick says her kids school
has been very vocal about any changes
moving forward you know the school that
our kids
attend if they felt like they weren't
prepared to have them back they would
let us know my kids can communicate with
me via email let me know if i need to
come and get them
you know i have to trust in what's
happening at the schools mary jane
bellezza live local now